good morning everyone thank thank you
all for coming so my name is Marc seaman
that if you want to know more about me
there's information they aren't blocked
upload a DK and you can follow me on
Twitter if you're interested in learning
what I have to say about various things
what I'm gonna do today is I'll try to
answer a couple of frequently asked
questions and we'll be - frequently
asked questions and we'll cover each one
in well it seems like we'll cover each
one in turn but what's actually going to
happen is that I'm gonna start with the
first one so that's gonna be act 1 this
is a you know three three-part talk or
three acts talk if you will so in Act
one we'll start by talking about the
first frequently asked question and I'll
talk about why you would you know ask
that question and why you should care
and at the end of that act I'm just
gonna let it you know simmer there for a
while and then move on to Act two
well I'm gonna you know start asking or
looking at another frequently asked
question that at first glance might seem
completely unrelated to the first one
and then we'll go through that
frequently asked question in act two and
once we arrive at a and a way to address
that question we now have enough
information to go back to the first one
from act 1 and so that's what's going to
happen in act 3 then we're going to go
back and look at how those things fit
together and arrive at I what I hope is
a nice and beautiful solution so the
first frequently asked question that I'm
going to address is how do I combine
dependency injection with a sink and a
weight without leaky abstractions that
is because if you can accept leaky
abstractions you've got to be okay so
we'll actually gonna start just looking
at what that might look like and then
we'll see what else we can do so we're
gonna have to look at some code in order
to be able to talk about these things
and I have my favorite scenario that I
always use if I can get away with it and
that is to pretend that I have to create
and I have to develop an online
restaurant reservation system I know
these are all out there but that's just
my favorite example scenario so you know
one of those things where if you want to
make a reservation at a restaurant
you find a form on the restaurant
website on app and you fill in the
details and you press submit and it
creates a little JSON document that gets
you know posted to some HTTP based API
and the code that we're going to look at
is that you know the backend code that
will receive that JSON document and
figure out what to do with it so we'll
start with the business logic or the
domain model if we go so I'll start by
just showing you some a method signature
here so in general just to get things to
fit on the slide I'm not going to show
you entire classes I'm just going to
show you members on classes so this is
just a method signature I'm gonna fill
in the method in a little while and I
want to talk a little bit about the
method signature before I fill it in
with with details so the idea here is
that we have a reservation as an input
argument and that's just a data transfer
object it's one of those things that
just contain whatever was in that JSON
document so the date the quantity the
name the email address those things
pretty straightforward and you'll notice
it returns a non herbal int so the idea
here the contract of this sort of
interaction is that the int is a
reservation ID so if you have a
reservation ID you have a reservation if
you get null you don't have a
reservation ID that means you don't have
a reservation and that might be various
reasons why you might not have a
reservation so if we do in dependency
injection we could have injected some
repository that's what people often do
so this is just you know this is
something that could be injected via a
constructor injection I'm not showing
you how that works because it's 2019 and
at this point I sort of expect that
people understand how constructor
injection works so this repository comes
in via the constructor and gets assigned
to this read-only property and now we
can access that dependency whenever we
need to so we could go and query it and
say well give me all the reservations
for that particular date once we have
that we can calculate the sum of all the
reserved seeds that are already been you
know reserved for that date and if we
also know the capacity of the restaurant
we can now make a business decision and
we can say
well if the capacity if the remaining
capacity is too little we'll have to
return null meaning unfortunately we
have to reject that preservation request
but if we get past that check we can now
call repository create with the
reservation and that returns a
reservation ID and we'll just you know
return that so at this point you'll
notice that there's absolutely no a sink
and a weight going on we'll get to that
in a moment but I just wanted to
establish what the baseline might look
like now I talked a little bit about
that try/except method as an overall
abstraction so if we don't remain driven
design we might want to say that's
actually an abstraction this is an
object called the maitre d the maitre d
is a role in in real restaurant business
based basically meaning the head waiter
that's the the person who makes the
decisions about whether or not we have
remaining tables if you walk into a
restaurant so we'll call it the maitre d
and just to be just because we can we
can actually use Unicode characters
there so we can use this doodle
a circumflex they're very very
uncomfortable to have to type that but
it's just make fun all right so now we
have our domain model in place how do we
compose all of those things what happens
at the boundary when that JSON document
actually arrives well you can have a
controller of some source and a post
method that will you know by convention
be invoked when you get an HTTP POST and
it has to return some sort of action
result which is basically an interface
that sort of models how an HTTP response
is gonna you know be rendered on the
wire and exactly how that works it's not
really important just it's just an HTTP
response polymorphically so if you're
doing dependency injection you tend to
do that all the way through so we could
take that Maitre D' domain abstraction
that we've created and inject that and
you know make it available as a
read-only property and that means we can
basically just you know delegate to that
get inaudible ID out of it and we can
just have a little look at whether it's
normal or not so if it's null we'll
return an internal server error so it
that's just a little helper method that
could sit on the base class of my
controller controller base class and
that just returns one of those action
results you know 500 internal server
error that HTTP was
otherwise we have another little helper
method here called okay that returns a
200k response and in this case you'll
notice we can go ID value because we've
checked whether it's null or not so it's
it's safe to access the value so we want
the HTTP response to include the
reservation ID so that any HTTP client
can go and do something with that
reservation ID so this is just a little
overview of what completely standard you
know dependency injection might look
like but then you go and say well the
reservations repository there this was
something that the the try/except method
required as a dependency so if we follow
the dependency inversion principle it's
the client that consumes the api that
gets to decide what that api looks like
and right now it looks like this because
try/except doesn't need it to do more
than this but then you can say all right
it's called a repository but really who
are we kidding we know that this is
really just a database right and if it's
really just a database we might actually
want to interact with this in an e
synchronous fashion so we want to do you
know asynchronous programming against
this because it might be more efficient
so how do we do that in c-sharp well
we'll have to change the wrists those
return types right now they're sort of
naked values in a reservation array or
an INT but if we change them to tasks
then we can do asynchronous programming
all right so that's fine I would say at
this point already this is a leaky
abstraction because the abstraction the
interface was defined in terms of what
the try except what that Maitre D'
object needs but now we've led some
implementation detail leaked through
into the design base coat because we
have a specific implementation in mind
that that we want to be asynchronous now
that's actually sort of leaking through
into our interface design and then you
might well say well but we're not really
kidding anyone anyone in any way we know
that this is a database so it's probably
okay that it's a synchronous and I would
probably say yeah okay fair enough let's
just go with that decision but if we
make that change we'll have to go back
to the Tri accept implementation and
make some changes as well and they're
small we just have
to add a sink and a weight but we also
have to change the return type to return
a task and when we do that we no longer
implement the interface so in order to
fix that we'll have to go and also
change the interface now this is where
I'm beginning to get a little bit
annoyed with the change because this was
supposed to be my domain model and now
the decision to have some asynchronous
database into action is leaking through
into my domain model and why does my
domain logic have to be asynchronous
this doesn't seem particularly
reasonable but it has to be because
otherwise it's not gonna compile so if
we make that change we also have to go
and make the change to the post method
on the controller again it's a small
change I just need to use the weight
keyword and the async keyword and at
this point I'm at the boundary of my
application so I'm done this now every
one of my code still compiles so it
complies again so so we're sort of done
with that so is this a problem no it's
probably okay you know that would
definitely be code bases where I'd say
yeah that's a compromise and it's a
reasonable compromise and I can live
with this so don't get me wrong here I'm
not saying that there's anything bad
with this I just think that we need to
be very explicit about the trade-offs we
are making and right now we are saying
well we're making a trade-off we are
actually you know letting an
implementation detail leak through into
how our abstractions are designed and
we'll live with that trade-off because
the cost is not too too high and that's
a reasonable enough stance to take so
you what I've covered here is known to
everyone who's ever done in is any sort
of asynchronous programming once you
start doing asynchronous programming it
has to be acing all the way and you
probably know this already it's nothing
new in this there's no other way to do
that and you know whenever whenever
someone tells me something like that oh
really
yeah I love those assertions because
there's I just have to come up with one
counter-argument one example where there
is another way and then I can disprove
something like that
so of course since I'm giving this talk
there is another way and I'm not saying
that the other way is superior to the
one that I've just shown you but I
believe in being able to make a choice
and I think a lot of people are not
aware of the other way and that's why
they say there is no other way so I want
you to know the other way and then you
can make a decision is one better or the
other and I think you know as always it
depends but you can make the decision if
you know how to do it if you don't know
how to do it you can't make that
decision so that's the end of Act one of
the talk we'll now go and you know put
that question aside for a little while
and we'll start by looking at a
completely different question and the
seemingly completely different question
is how do I get the value of my monad
and the short answer by the way I'm not
going to assume that you know what a
monad is so we'll cover that in a little
while but the summary of how you'd
answer this question is mu there is a
tradition in Zen Buddhist philosophy
that associates the word mu this sort of
means void or null or emptiness
something like that and there's a
tradition that associated this as
meaning unasked the question basically
you know if someone asks you a question
instead of saying yes or no sometimes
you might answer mu and the idea here is
that it means the question actually
doesn't make much sense now if you're
interested in a Western perspective on
this you could read zen and the art of
motorcycle maintenance but that's sort
of like a philosophy book so maybe you
should just go and read goodish epochal
instead because that is actually you
know sort of a programmers book there
but both of them are pretty good and
they offer a Western perspective on this
idea of uh Nazca the question and
they're just good books in themselves so
why not might not want to greet them
so basically sometimes we run into these
sort of problems where a person who's
asking a question might actually ask a
question that doesn't really make any
sense and they don't know that because
they're just getting started with
you know Buddhist philosophy or they're
just getting started with the new
programming language or a new framework
or maybe a new programming paradigm this
gives rise to what is known as the XY
problem the X - problem is a question
you often run into in you know when you
have questions and answers and people
are trying to learn new stuff it's such
a common thing on Stack Overflow that
Stack Overflow has a FAQ about that but
in general the idea here is that when
you're learning something new and you're
sort of struggling with how to do things
in whatever the new way is sometimes you
have a goal in mind and we could call
that goal Y and either consciously or
unconsciously you probably have a series
of steps in mind that that you think
will enable you to reach the goal Y so
if you're an object-oriented program are
trying to learn functional programming
for example you might may say well I I
know how object oriented programming I
would accomplish my goal that would
involve a series of steps and then it
turns out that you stuck on one of those
steps just stuck on X and you go and ask
other people how do I do X and then the
expert will say why would you ever want
to do X and then you can get really you
know you can get offended and think that
Stack Overflow is not a friendly place
and sometimes it's not because people
can ask that you know why why would you
want to do that if they can ask that in
a really unpleasant way but sometimes if
you in you know if you engage in a
conversation you may actually be able to
arrive at what was originally implicit
that you're really trying to accomplish
the goal why and once the expert
understands that they say oh okay in
this case in this paradigm what you want
to do is Z and set will enable you to
achieve your goal
so there's a completely different way of
doing things
so this happens a lot with monads and
often the question is very specific but
you can sort of generalize it to say how
do I get the value out of my mu net or
you don't because you have to do that
instead and getting the value out of the
MU net is not the way to go about it so
I'm not assuming you know what a monad
is so let's cover that once a monad well
it's a function you can flatten them
okay that's very helpful
once a functor I'm not assuming you know
the
things and I know that functors and
monads are some of those words that
often you know sounds scary to a lot of
people it's really not a but it's not a
difficult concept to craft so I'll see
if I can make you understand that even
if you don't know what it is without too
much fancy terminology so we'll start by
talking about what we could call darts a
container so basically a functor is a
data container and I'm not talking about
a docker container and I'm not talking
about a dependency injection container
I'm not even talking about a shipping
container but you can think of a data
containers just a generically typed
container of values and in order to for
that control of container to be a
functor it must support what we call a
structure preserving map so there's some
values inside of that container and you
can sort of translate what what's inside
the container and the output of that
would be a new container with the
translated values inside so the the most
familiar example of this is just a
collection so here's a collection of
numbers it could be an array a list of
tea any ienumerable of tea whatever
you'd like and one of the ways you could
translate that is just at one to each of
the numbers and now you still have a
collection so it's still the same sort
of container but you translated whatever
goes on inside of it and likewise you
can say well instead of add one you
could turn all the numbers into strings
or you could figure out whether they're
even or odd and turn them into boolean
values so what we mean by structure
preserving is that we're preserving the
structure of the original input
container in this case collections have
a size you know there's six elements in
the input so all the output collections
also have a size of six and there's the
there's an order the reason why you know
the output collections have the ordering
that they have of the elements is
because it's determined by the input and
order so that's basically what it means
you know what a structure of a container
is depends on what sort of container it
is and right now we're just using a
collection as an example another thing
we can do with those things is you'll
notice that the output is also a
container it's a container of the same
kind of thing so we could use that as an
input for another step so you could say
well after we've added one week
turn things into strings and this
shouldn't be surprising to - she - she
sharp developers at all in she's sharp
we would do something like this where we
can say let's create a new array for
example or a list of T whatever and then
you know that this structure preserving
map in c-sharp is not called map as in
all the other languages
it's called select so you just say let's
add one to each of the numbers inside
that array and the next step is just to
turn them into strings and now you have
yourself an array of strings so this is
an example of a functor is a data
container that contains a structure
preserving map it's just one example and
we'll see some other ones later on at
this point you might probably say well
why would anyone ever ask the question
how do I get the value out of my array
because you understand that that is a
nonsensical question right you know in
this example there's not one value
there's six values so this doesn't make
sense to ask the question how to get the
value out of it and even even worse you
know erase all other collections might
be empty in which case there is not a D
value there's no value inside of it so
no one asks that question how do I get
the value out of my array so what makes
people ask the question what how do I
get the value out of my monad and I
believe the reason is you know if you've
ever when you've ever learned link and
you written the Microsoft documentation
about how link how select works there's
nothing in that documentation that tells
you that what you're looking at is a
functor even though it is and there's
nothing that tells you that is also a
monad which it also is we haven't
covered but that is we'll get back to
that so I believe that what happens is
the first time people actually encounter
the concept of a function and a monad
it's not in this context and even though
you probably have done things like this
for years you're not aware that you're
working with functors no net so what I
think happens is that people often
encounter the context of a monad in with
different types of containers so there
there's a class of containers that we
could call unit containers and that's
just my own made-up terminology there
but but all of these have in common is
that there can guarantee to contain
exactly one value so for that class it
actually makes sense to ask the question
how do I get the value out of the
container because you can in most cases
now let's look at an example so lazy of
T has been around in the dotnet
framework for just forever basically and
it's a generically type container it
doesn't have a select method in the base
class library itself but you can easily
add an extension method that takes you
know lazy of T and turns it into a lazy
of TB assault you just need to have a
function that can turn a tea into a tea
result value and the implementation is
just a one-liner so if you if you have
an extension method like this you could
write code that goes like this so you
can say let's create a new lazy of int
and even though it has this threat that
sleep before 10 seconds inside of it
this whole expression just completes
immediately because that's the idea of a
lazy computation so now you have a lazy
of end you can use the new selects
extension method to turn it into a lose
your string and this still completes
immediately so this preserves the
structure of what it means to be a lazy
computation or it preserves the
invariance we could say what we expect
from a lazy of string is that we'd
expect it to remain lazy until we force
evaluation at which point it will block
for 10 seconds and then if we try to
access it again it'll give us the result
immediately because it memorizes the
results that's what we be that's what we
expect lazy of T to do and select
preserves those invariants so this is a
structure preserving map so it's pretty
straightforward to turn lazy of T into a
functor by you know creating a little
select extension method and you can do
the same thing with tasks of T you will
notice the implementation is a little
bit different but the idea is the same
and that means you can write some code
that goes like this and again it'll
return immediately even though you have
that task delay and you can call you
know X dot select on your task of in to
get a task of string and again that just
returns immediately it's only when you
try to await it that it will block
probably will blog because it's not
finished running at that point and again
if you do it again it'll return
immediately so everything you expect
from a task of string still holds even
though you contact select method so
select in this case again is a structure
for serving translation if it serves
what it means to be an asynchronous
computation so this means that both lacy
of tea and task of tea are other types
of functors there are other examples of
functors so functor is this very
abstract idea that we have some sort of
container that supports a structure
preserving map and so far I've just
written it with extension method syntax
but it turns out that I can actually
write this in query syntax as well so
normally when you see this query syntax
from I in Ex select you you mostly think
of this as being something that is
enabled for ienumerable so that if X
designer will be loved int then Y is
inferred to be a Niner mobile of string
but since we added those to select
method it turns out that this syntax in
c-sharp also works for lacy event and it
also works for tasks event so adding the
appropriate select method lights of that
language feature and the reason it does
that is because that language feature is
based on that abstraction you know Eric
Meyer who was involved in creating that
feature knew all about functions known
as bank when did they did that and he
said well we'll just have the the
concept of a monad and a functor and
that was that's what we're gonna base
the language syntax on right so this
sort of hopefully I hope explains what a
firm tree is so now we just need to
figure out okay so what's a monad so as
I told you a monad is a functor you can
flatten so what does that mean when when
it's a function not flat well we can
start again we can go back to thinking
about collections for a little while so
if you have a string like foo comma bar
this is one string and there's an
instance method on string called split
that enables you to split over a given
character so if you run the ad you get
an array of strings and split on the
comma now that's fine
what if you have an array of comma
separated strings like this one
you say I'd like to split all the
comma-separated strings into separate
strings so you can do a select and then
you can say s that split on the comma
but if you do that you'll get an estate
array this is an array of arrays and you
say well that's not what I want I would
very much like to just have a flat list
so I want to flatten that listed array
so there's a method for that and it's
called select many and the reason it's
called sonic many is because what
happens inside that lambda expression
produces many values you know split
produces many values and so you just say
well I have something that happens
inside the lambda expression that
produces many values
I would like to flatten as I go and
that's what select many does and that's
why it's called that and now you just
have a flat list there now if you have a
select many method and it's well behaved
as this one is then it's a monad because
you can flatten the listed list so
that's what that's basically what a
monad is there's a little bit more to it
but that's the intuition you have you
need to have it's nothing much more -
it's not mysterious it's just practical
so could you also have a mr. task for
example well what if you want to add two
tasks Vin's together and you say well
I'd like to use this new thing I've just
learned about structure preserving maps
so let's see if I can do that with the
Select method so you might write
something like this and say well okay
I'll do extra select and then that means
I can access the integer inside X and
I'll call that I and then I can sort of
add the other one but I have to await
that so that's a little bothersome when
you notice that the output Z is a task
of tasks of int now how do you get the
value out of that well you can actually
go a weight away jet sort of I was a
little bit surprised when I saw that but
you're safe now what of this worked it
does it compiles it actually works but
you know that's not really that's really
not as nice as you'd like it to be so
instead you know you could have if you
have a select many method and you could
just you know add an extension method
for that as well I'm not going to show
you that but you can look it up that
means you can now flatten as you go so
you can say well Z is now just a normal
task of Ind and that means I just have
to await at once and you can even now
use query syntax so you can use this
cartesian syntax where is
even if I have multiple sources of
asynchronous computation I can just go
from from multiple times and that takes
away a lot of the need for all that a
sink and a wait in the only await
keyword you now need is to get the value
out of out of set so that's a pretty
pretty decent way to be able to have to
write these things and again the reason
why they cut this syntax this language
syntax lights up is because you now turn
tasks into a monad
so to summarize there definitely
containers data containers that look
like you can get the value out of them
so if you have a lazy of string you can
get the string out of the lazy of string
by forcing evaluation and sort of the
same thing goes for tasks of things and
this is not even constrained to c-sharp
you know you have the same situation in
F sharp where we have something called
async of string and you can get the
value out of that as well by running it
synchronously basically means the same
thing as under waiting is and even in
haskell we have all sorts of unit
containers the simplest one being one
called identity where you know if you
have an identity of string you can get
the value out of it by running a
function called run identity there are
more of those in haskell as well so it's
I think what happens is that if you sort
of get your feet wet with the concept of
of functors and monads in this sort of
context it's you know the brain really
likes to attempt to do some pattern
matching and now you think well a monad
is something where you know ultimately I
can get the value out of it because it's
just you know represents some sort of
you know computation and this is true
for these things but not in general and
and we still know that you know
collections are also monads and we know
that it doesn't make any sense to ask
that question for all the collections
but people tend to not really realize
that collections are known as so web
where yeah where we often see the people
run into problems is when we encounter
what we could call semi containers these
are contained again my own made-up
terminology here but these are
containers that may or may not contain a
single value so they sort of look like
unit containers but they're not quite
because they may also be empty so that's
why I call them semi containers because
semi means half so they're sort of like
half one half another thing so we can
start with something that most of you
probably heard about either also no
level of tea so if you have an AA level
of IND for example you saw an example of
that previously we can sort of try to
check whether it's null and if it's not
no we know that it's safe to access ID
dot value and in this case we're trying
to return a new customer with an integer
you know a customer ID inside of it so
that's fine but if you want to return a
customer that means you know what you
need to also deal with the case where a
ID is null
there is an else branch and you need to
deal with that else bound so what do you
do I know so a lot of people don't
really know how what to do here it's not
at all clear what you should do here so
people throw exceptions and now if you
package this into a little milk a helper
method that method will have the return
type customer and if you then say it and
tell me I haven't written this now you
can just go ahead and use that helper
method I'll just so I'll just go this
gives me a customer called that and that
compiles fine and I'm literally unaware
that when I try to run the code it's
gonna throw exceptions left and right so
this is sort of like if you create code
write it in this style that's just going
to create a minefield that can I explode
in your face at runtime and you have
absolutely no idea unless you actually
try to you know read and become very
intimate with the entire code base so it
doesn't scale and it doesn't fit our
brains it's not a good way to structure
code so it'd be nice if we could do
something else with you know based on
this idea of a structure preserving map
and we can actually turn novel of T into
a functor by implementing a little
extension method again called select the
trends you know a novel of T into a
novel of T result you will notice one
constraint here T and T be salt has to
be struct because that's how no above T
is defined this does enable you to write
something like this where you can say
let I can translate
you know novel of int into no level of
bool and that means in this case I could
return that result and I don't have to
you know throw an exception in the case
where things are no
you know the cola needs in the corner
we'll have to figure out what to do you
know in both of those cases so it's a
well that's really neat this compose is
much better can I use that also for you
know creating you know if I have that ID
and can I sort of translate that into a
customer that'd be really nice because
then I don't have to throw an exception
and this doesn't work unfortunately this
doesn't compile because T rissoles has
to be a struct and customer is not a
struct that's a class it's not a value
type it's a reference type so that
doesn't work but it'd be really nice if
we could do this because then we would
have a composable way to deal with you
know things sometimes not working so
what we can do instead is we can say
well we could we can't loosen the
constrain inaudible of T but we can make
our own generically type container and
we'll call it maybe of T because that's
what it's typically called it also
sometimes it's known as option of T but
the idea is the same so this is a
generic to type container and the idea
is that it may or may not contain a
value so the way that we construct
classes of objects of this class is that
there's two constructor overload it's
one that doesn't take any arguments and
it just sets the has item flag to false
and then we have another constructor
overloading item as input and sets the
flag to true and remembers the item for
later on so now we have maybe of T could
represent the presence of a value but
also the absence of a value okay so this
is a generic type container maybe of T
can we make it a functor yes of course
because otherwise I wouldn't talk about
it
so we'll need to add a select method now
it doesn't have to be an extension
method here it's just an instance method
on maybe of T that returns maybe of T
result so this is another way you can
implement that and basically you just
check the flag and you say well if has
item is true that means item exists we
now you know item is of the type T we
have a selector that turns T into T
resolved and then we'll just package
that in a maybe of T result so that's a
populated maybe otherwise we'll just
return an empty one
so this is a structure for serving math
because it translates populated Maeby's
into populated maybes it translates
empty babies into empty maybe so that
preserves the structure of the after
maybe idea and not only can we do this
with select we can also do it with
select many the implementation looks a
little bit different but it turns out
that maybe is also a monad good so what
we can do with maybe something like this
for example so we could say let's have a
little wrapper around this idea of being
able to pass a string into an integer
and you'd say why do we need the wrapper
why can't we just do in to try pass as
you know it's basically in the in the
framework already and I say well the
problem here is that again it doesn't
compose very well and often when you do
that if check there and check whether
try pass returns true you know what do
you do in the case where it's returns
false and this is again where people
often throw exceptions and you know the
way that we can do it when we're a bit
to return a maybe is that we don't have
to throw exceptions so we'll just say
well if in try pass returns true will
return to populate it maybe otherwise we
return an empty one and you can do some
the same thing with you know trying to
pass a string into a date it's just call
it date time but try pass instead of in
to try pass and if you have something
like this I'll show you a little example
here what you can do is you imagine that
you have to write a little application
that enables people to rent a car and so
you will ask people they'll ask your
potential users please input the date
where you'd like to to rent the car so
it may have a little function they're
called collect date and that just you
know asks the question you know user
types in something and then you have a
string that the user typed in and then
you will try to pass that into a date
time value and you get a maybe update
time and then you ask the user okay for
how many days would you like to rent the
car and that returns the string as well
and you can use your try pass in Toba
method to turn that into a maybe event
and you're probably going to ask some
other questions as well and once you're
done asking all those questions what you
really would like to do is to collect
all those all that information into a
contract because a contract has some
some functionality that enables you to
calculate a price and stuff like that so
you can go and use query syntax and you
can say well let's translate let's map
all of this into a maybe of contract
so we'll say from D and MD D is now date
time
if from I and M I is now an int so again
we are using this Cartesian from from
from from that is enabled by having a
monad and then finally you can select
the contract based on all that
information so now you have a maybe of
contract if all the maybes were
populated you have a populated maybe of
contracts if one of them turns out not
to work you have an empty contract so
this is sort of like a pretty principle
and very easy way to do some input
validation there are more sophisticated
ways to do this as well but this is sort
of like a pretty easy and fast way of
doing things now what you probably want
to do is to show a quote to a user and
this is where things start to go wrong
for for a lot of people because they say
well the contract class contains some
information that enables me to calculate
a price so I want to show a price to
user so I might want to do something
like this and say well if MC has item I
know that I can you know access that
item and that's a cut that's a contract
and then I can call this calculate price
or rather I think I can do this but it
turns out that you can't and this is by
design I deliberately design the maybe
of T class so that this is not possible
now these things exist but they're
private and they're not exposed and it
is by design that they're not exposed
because you're not meant to do stuff
like this you know because this is
unsafe this is brittle you know because
what happens if has item is false
where does that leave something like you
will Q now be initialized to be 0 and
we'll end up having 0 prices on you know
on your quotes in your quotes for the
user that's that doesn't sound like a
good idea so you're not supposed to do
this so let's reset the the code and see
what else can we do well maybe supports
a structure preserving map so if we stay
within the context of having maybes we
can actually just translate the contract
into a quote into a decimal so we can do
something like this but we can just call
the contracts calculate price inside the
context of maybe and the result is a
maybe of decimal so I call that MQ
because it's maybe quote and this is
safe this is not kind of throw
exceptions there are no reason to write
all that if-else code in order to do
this this is just you know you can just
do C you can always safe to do this so
this sort of gives you an illustration
of the answer to the question how do you
get the value out of my monad well you
don't you inject the desired behavior
into the monad and that's what we did
here I took that you know calculate
price method and I just said well
whatever happens inside that maybe
context inside that container this just
needs to happen there huh and then all
is good and and that just means now I
have a maybe I've decimal and it's safe
and then you go yeah well okay but
ultimately I need to produce a result
because I need to show that quote to the
user so how to do that well let's go
back to collections for a little while
here's a series of numbers sometimes you
also have the same problem with
collections you need to produce a result
so what you can do is for example with
numbers you could add them together and
there's an extension method for that and
now we just have the sum of all those
numbers but sometimes maybe you want to
do something else maybe you want to
multiply the numbers together instead of
at them and there's no special extension
method for that so what you can do
instead is you can use the general
purpose method called aggregate and
aggregate it enables you to give it any
sort of lambda expression that just
tells it how to you know make it turn
two numbers into one and in this case
we're just saying x times y so we're
just you know multiply the numbers
together and this works as long as the
array has values which it does in this
case but if the array is empty that
would fail unless we also give it some
sort of the fallback value and this is
called the seed so in this case I'm
using an overload to aggregate that
actually says well start with one and
then add all them multiply all the
numbers together because when you
multiply something with one it just
stays whatever the other number is so
that's the safe thing to do but that
also means now I can return one if the
array was empty which it's it's not here
I know but if it was now boringly this
just returns zero because there is a
zero inside
Rea's are not very interesting but the
concept of being able to aggregate you
know potentially many values or even
zero values into a single value we can
translate that concept to maybe also so
I'm going to call it match instead of
just calling it aggregate for various
reasons but the idea is that this is
again an instance method on maybe of tea
and you can say well if the has item
flag is said I know that I can access
item this is a value of the type T and I
have a function called just and don't
don't ask me what it why it's called
that it's just that that's the name we
usually use we have a function called
just that can translate a tea into a tea
resolved value and you'll notice that's
what we need to return now if has item
based false item is not available and we
still need to return the tea result
value but then we have the fallback net
value here called nothing but sort of
corresponding to that seed you saw
before so that means we can always
aggregate that or we can always collapse
any maybe object into a single value
even though it might we don't know
whether it's populated or empty right so
we can go back to now to try to answer
the question how do I combine dependency
injection with async and a weight
without leaky abstraction that's that is
so where we left is that we said well it
looks like we have to do a sync all the
way and it turns out that there may be
another way so what we need to do first
it's a little maneuver that we often use
when we do functional programming and
that is we say we'll have to move our
impure operations to the boundary of the
system so the idea here is that the core
of the system is where our business
logic is and at the boundary of the
system is where interaction with the
real world happens so this is a type of
architecture that resembles ports and
adapters quite a bit this is a
well-known object oriented architecture
so what does it mean for an operation to
be impure well we could say what's a
pure operation what's a pure function a
pure function must may have two
qualities it must be deterministic and
it must have no side effects and we have
two examples of things that violate one
of the other of those rules now read
reservations for example goes and reads
from a database this is what we would
term not deterministic because
the definition of determinism is that if
I give you the same input
I would always expect to get the same
output back for any given input it
should always return the same output and
that's not the case when you go and
query the database if you go and query
the database to say give me give me all
the reservations for next Friday well
you'll get some reservations and then if
you go and do it the next day still the
same input date now you make it it's
different set of reservations so that's
output so that's not deterministic and
yet then you'd say well but it's
completely determined by the state of
the database yes but we do not consider
the state of the database to be part of
the function so from the perspective of
looking at the function it is
non-deterministic so we want to move
this to the boundary of the system
another example of an impure operation
that we have is repository to create
because this is going to create a row in
the database and that's a side-effect
and functions are not supposed to have
side effects so both of these we want to
move and I don't want to get rid of them
I just want them to take place somewhere
else I want to move them to the boundary
of the system you know the post method
where we deal with the incoming JSON
document and we return an HTTP response
and that's where that sort of stuff
needs to happen the first one is the
easiest one now you'll notice that we
unconditionally call this read
reservations method here so you say well
okay so why don't why does the try
accept method need to do this could we
just make it a precondition for calling
the method to say well someone else
needs to do this be this work upfront
and then you can call the try accept
method so how do you do that well it's
just if you want to make it a
precondition you just make it a method
argument so you just say well just give
me the reservations and I'll give you an
answer now this is pretty
straightforward unfortunately things get
worse and sometimes they have to get
worse before they get better now the
thing that gets worse is that in order
for us to compile we have to change that
I met Rudy interface and then you'd say
well okay if if there ever was a leaky
abstraction this must be it because now
you definitely allowed a particular
implementation to leak through into the
action in itself yeah I said okay so you
complain about the task but this is much
worse and I completely agree this is
much worse now fortunately what I'm
doing here is a series of refactoring
steps and I'm not done but right now in
this step I have made something worse
I completely admit that now just trust
me when I say we'll have to change this
interface several times before we're
done but in the end it's gonna be fine
so just trust me on that all right when
we change the interface though we'll
need to also change the way that that
post method the boundary of the system
how that interacts with the maitre d so
we're using dependency injection and we
have that injected Maitre D' object
already we could also just take a
dependency on the repository here
because well why not you know there's no
rule that says that you can't have a
dependency appearing in multiple places
so if we have a dependency on the
repository we can call repository that
read reservations and now we have the
reservations we can call Maitre D' to
try accept and the rest of the code is
the same as before you'll notice that we
still have this thing here where we're
doing a check on whether or not ID is
null and we are getting the value out of
the monad actually they're going ID dot
value and this is sort of a style of
coding that we're trying to get rid of
so we'll look at that in a little while
all right so so this takes care of one
of the impure operations we've now moved
that to the boundary of the application
now what about repository create now
this one is a little bit harder because
it doesn't always happen you know it
only happens in certain cases you will
notice that there is this little if
statement up there that may return null
in which case repository that create
never gets cold
so what we need to do is somehow if we
want to move the repository to create
method to the caller they are making the
caller's responsibility to make sure
that this happens we need to make sure
that the caller understands that this is
what it needs to do I'm talking about
the calling code the calling code of the
developer who's writing the calling code
needs to understand that this is the
sort of interaction that is being
expected that you sort of need to call
repository create if we just
to accept the reservation so how do we
communicate that decision to the caller
well how do we communicate a decision in
any way well what we did before was that
we returned a novel image and you
remember that the idea here was they say
well if you have a reservation ID you
have a reservation if you get null you
don't have a reservation so this is a
way we can communicate a decision what
I'd like to do is instead of return a
inaudible int you know if I move
repository to create that's the method
that returned that creates an integer if
I move that report that method to the
boundary of the system I no longer have
an int to return so what should I return
instead well I'd like to return
something like an inaudible of
reservation instead and but
unfortunately I can't do that because
this we have this problem with nullable
of tea that it it's constrained to only
be struts so I can't do an audible of
reservation because that's a class so
what I'd like to do is to refactor to a
maybe of tea and I'll do this in steps
so I'll just start by just you know
changing nullable of into maybe event
and then we'll do the other thing later
on so if we make this change if you look
at the pay attention to the top line
there and the return value task of
knowledge into I'll now change it to
maybe event and the rest of the curve
basically remains the same the new
things is that instead of returning null
I'm returning an empty maybe and instead
of returning an ID instead of returning
an integer I'm now returning a populated
maybe event but apart from that this is
basically the same now we still need to
go and change the maitre d
it'll be good it's not right now but
it'll be it'll be good once we're done
and we also need to change the post
method so you'll notice right what what
happened now is that instead of getting
a knowable
int that we could check for null now we
have this maybe of int and I've
deliberately designed it so that we
cannot check for null here we can't
write this if-else expressions that that
people seem to be so fond of but really
explodes when you least expect them to
we want to have something that's
actually safer so this safer way to do
this is to say well okay you can't check
for null but you can call that match
and that's why you know that aggregation
visit and that's why I am I added that
so if we use named arguments I can say
the for the nothing argument
I'll return internal server error so 500
internal server and in the case where
it's populated it's called just it needs
a little function so I'll just write a
little lambda expression that receives
as input the ID and just returns 200
okay with that ID so I D when if I get
it if that just function runs then ID is
an integer and I don't have to check for
anything and both internal server error
and okay return an action results at
this point I'm good alright we're now in
a position where we can move that method
call to the boundary of the system so
when if I do that if I take it away from
the try/except method here
I no longer have an integer to return so
I'll need to return a maybe of
reservation instead so I'll do that
so you'll notice again if I decide not
not to accept the reservation I'll
return an empty maybe a reservation if I
decide to accept the reservation I'll
return a populated one I'll have to
change a Maitre D' but if I do that what
I now have is a maybe of reservation now
according to my contract with all the
HTTP clients in the case of success I
promised the HTTP clients to return and
200 okay that contains an integer the
reservation ID now right now I don't
have a reservation ID so how well should
I get that from well we know that maybe
a of T is a functor so we can make a
structure for serving map and we can say
well we can map the reservation if it's
there to an integer by calling
repository create with the reservation
are so again this is safe to do because
the that lambda expression is only going
to run if it's actually populated so
that our will always be there so now I
have instead of having a maybe of
reservation I have a maybe of int Wow
actually I have a maybe of a task of an
int so that makes things a little bit
more complicated but we already learned
the task of T is a monad we learned that
may be of T is a monad it turns out that
this stack of monad
is also a monad so all we've learned
about what we can do with monads still
hold right now it does make the rest of
the syntax a little bit awkward but
again this is just an interim result
it'll be better in a little while but
right now this match implementation
looks a little bit clunky
well it'll be beautiful once we're done
I promise if we go back now and look at
the try except implementation though it
turns out that we have a compiler
warning it says this async method lacks
a weight of raters and yes it does
you know it says public async of it then
there's nothing that says a weight
anywhere so why does it need to be
asynchronous well it doesn't so let's
not make it anything so this is what's
about bothered me all along you know
that my domain logic had to be
asynchronous now it doesn't have to be
asynchronous anymore so this is just
much better so if I make that change I
again have to change the maitre d
interface but if I make that change
there's just one thing I need to change
here you know if this is the picture
from before where I did you know awake
Maitre D' to try accept and if I make
Chagas try accept synchronous I just
removed the awake keyword so maybe you
weren't where maybe you didn't know
where to look so we'll just do it again
you know this was before it said a wait
maitre d to try a try except and now we
just remove the wait keyword it's a
pretty pretty straightforward that's not
a lot of a change we can go back and
look at the implementation details of
the maitre d object again and we'll
notice another thing that repository
there it's no longer being used we don't
need that dependency so let's get rid of
that dependency so what we have now is
pretty close to what we would call a
pure function it's not quite because
that is a accepted flag it's set to true
so there's a little bit of state
mutation going on still but the
important part is so this sort of like
pure in in quotes but what goes what's
important here is that this method is
now entirely deterministic what happens
in this method is entirely determined by
the input arguments to the to the method
itself so that means I can control
exactly what happens by making sure that
it gets the appropriate arguments
so if we go back and look at the
boundary of the application we'd say
well okay why do we even have that
Maitre D' dependency there on the top
and then you know someone else might
come and say well well we still need
that because we do unit testing and we
need to somehow be able to stop it out
and say well we need to control how the
Maitre D' behaves and we can create a
stub out of that and that enables us to
control how it behaves
I noticed and now I say well it is now
deterministic that means you can control
how it behaves without creating a stub
out of it you can control how it behaves
by making sure that it gets the
appropriate input values so there's no
reason to have that as a dependency
anymore we can just new up the Maitre D'
object and just be done with it so now
we know no longer have the dependency on
that Maitre D' interface that means we
don't need it anymore
so this is why it all turned out to be
well in the end because you know there's
no leaky abstraction because the
interface is gone now the domain
abstraction is still embedded in that
concrete class so we still have some
domain modeling going on but it's just
we don't need to have an interface the
object is fine an object is also an
abstraction you can just look at the
static you know public API of it and say
well that's how it's supposed to work
and you need to know the details of it
so we into a little bit of cleanup here
because it doesn't look that pretty at
the moment so we can move things around
and we all might arrive at something
like this now exactly how we do that I
don't have time to cover but I'll be
publishing some some articles where you
can go through all of this if you're
interested in how that actually works
but what we'll notice now that we have
some sort of a pipeline of operations
going on we'll start by calling
repository table read reservations and
then we go select and then we go select
many and then we go match on that you
know towards the end so you say there's
clearly a monad going on here because
otherwise we wouldn't be able to call
select many because that's what you know
sort of this sign of a monad so which
monad is it well it's the task of T
monad or the asynchronous monad so
everything here is asynchronous apart
from the
main logic what I've done is I've
injected in a Maitre D' to try accept
into this asynchronous context but that
object is entirely unaware of its
context it is happily thinking that it's
doing synchronous work even though it's
actually not but from its perspective
it's just running synchronously but you
know in the context it's actually turns
out that it is running asynchronously so
everything that needs to be asynchronous
is still synchronous we call repository
dot read reservations you know that
asynchronously Reif reads from the
database and then we do a little bit of
synchronous business logic because it
you know this is just a decision that
needs to be made and it doesn't need to
be long-running and then after that we
call repository dot create and that
asynchronously go and communicates the
database increase our role in the
database and then we return an HTTP
response and all of that runs
asynchronously as well because you can
see it still returns a task of I action
result so everything that needs to be
asynchronous is asynchronous all the
stuff that didn't have to be
asynchronous because that would be a
leaky abstraction it's not so now we
have the best of both worlds so we can
sort of conclude that the way we can
combine Ti with async and a weight
without leaky abstractions is to inject
the desired behavior into the async
monad or the task monad if you prefer
that and we know that because we already
knew the answer to that general question
there how do I get the value out of my
monad well you don't even take the
desired behavior so what we could call
this is we could call it behavior
injection instead of dependency
injection so if you thought that you
would like to learn more about this I
have tons of articles unblocked declare
that DK that walks you through what a
functor is all the code that I've shown
you here today I have a couple of
articles written that will walk you
through this entire code example and
that the code itself will be on github
as well these articles are not published
yet but I have written them so it's not
not an entirely empty promise to say I
will soon publish them so if you want to
keep abreast of that you can subscribe
to the blog or you can follow me on
Twitter and I'll you know notify you
when these things are out and with that
I'll conclude the talk I will not take
any questions because I only have a
couple of minutes left but I'm happy to
talk to you so you can come and talk to
me afterwards so you can you know catch
me outside and I'll be happy to talk to
you but otherwise I'll let you go two
minutes before the other session stops
and you can you know go wherever you
need to go well thank you so much for
coming and listening to me
[Applause]